I'm sure nothing's gonna jump out of me
at all why would that be hello everybody
my name is Markiplier and welcome back
well let me hold on
there we go
wait
oh
Welcome to Dead Space the last time I
played this was probably back in 2012
this game came out in 2008 and this is
the remake
featuring Isaac Clarke and his intrepid
Adventures on the USG ishimura
oh I wish I could talk to you
I'm sorry
I'm sorry about everything I just wish I
could talk to someone
it's all
falling apart here
believe what's happening
strange
such a little thing
sir Nicole yeah first deferred from her
in weeks
five minutes now you still got that
thing on repeat
so you really miss her
the instrument is not a job you turn
down but six months apart with only vid
calls
it's rough
easy to say the wrong thing
I don't blame you I'd listen to my
girlfriend over him and reciting
security protocols forewarned his
forearm Miss Daniels
so you keep saying here we go nice clean
re-entry
imagine six months staring at that Chuck
of Rock
to an independent Miner that's Paradise
Aegis seven is one of the richest fines
in CEC history
some prospecting teams set up for life
now where is she
there
confirming visual contact with USG
ishimura
what a beauty
biggest planet cracker in her class you
know
and it looks like they already popped
the cork why is it so dark
to be able to see your running lights
yeah
I'll get us into hailing range someone's
got to be waiting up for us just be
careful on the approach I'm not taking
any chances with the cec's pride and joy
no chances huh is that why you were
digging into my Personnel files before
we left you track your file access
a computer analyst comes with a job
I ran standard CEC background checks
miss Daniels you want to work in the big
leagues you have to play ball
sir we're inhaling range
this is the emergency maintenance team
of the USG Kelly responding to your
distress call how many shoes
Kimora do you copy come in this is a USG
calendar
no
come on someone picked up the damn phone
the hell is that
uh it sounds like their communication
array is busted maybe a broken encoder
Daniels and I can handle it in 48 hours
max
I hope so
Jen Johnson take us in
gravity
automated docking
go okay I'm ready
emergency stabilizer there the blue
light you might slow us down
[Music]
everyone okay
I'm good I'll live
and Johnston all right it's my ankle
might be broken
oh [__] but better than a broken neck or
worse
good column that stabilizer Isaac thanks
what the [__] going on with flight
control that guidance system's a death
track better attitude repair list Jen
what's our damage calms are down we lost
support booster
we've got a fire in one of the
stabilizers and
Singularity course of mess
could be worse this Singularity core
Johnston stay with the Killian we'll
send a medic everyone else with me
so Isaac's voice sounds the same uh
Hammond's voice sounds different Daniels
might be different it's hard to tell God
it's been so long
and obviously it looks beautiful well I
said this when I was playing Callisto
protocol I'm not used to playing uh AAA
games that actually look extremely
pretty and push my 40 90 that I have to
its limits
um it is lovely hey how you doing up
here
did you stay here before you mind me
looking over you or something uh
uh yeah
whatever worse
you go on I'll get it strapped up okay
all right you so tough you're so big and
brave and strong I'd Pat you on the
shoulder but I I feel like Deb would be
unprofessional so I'm just gonna stare
loomingly at whatever you're doing okay
goodbye now
man it is nuts I know people probably
have mixed feelings about a remake in
general
standard procedure Ms Daniels we'll
register them in the flight times uh
standard procedure hello yeah but what I
don't mind about this one is because I
feel like Dead Space 3 was such a
detriment to the series as a whole that
it kind of impeded any progress in Dead
Space in general so if this reboot
allows the entire franchise to get back
up on its feet again which it's great
franchise and it actually is really
really engaging interesting I love the
Universe I actually read the books on
some of these not all a few of them
guess we better go I'm on the way
you don't have to shout them literally
two steps behind you well like 14 what
whatever don't matter
and look at it
like I don't know what they've changed I
don't know how much they've changed but
one of the things that
yeah why would they do that but one of
the good things about this game is it
kind of changed uh the way games were
played because this one was an extremely
immersive experience also by the way I
didn't mention
um but I am wearing the cloak Dead Space
collab you can tell everyone how much
life you have and how much are your
spaces bar is full with the new no Dead
Space collab there's a whole bunch of
stuff available through the link in the
description below I'm just gonna watch
that wow look at that so go check it out
cloakbrand.com new Dead Space stuff all
right what do I miss here can I start
stomping on things yet I don't think so
trash can
yes
mellow you're not Hammond who are you
thank you oh
Reagan synced collect Kinesis and stasis
modules from acting chief engineer Jacob
temple location
better and for he not found
hmm
well that's weird same for the chief
engineer what is wrong with their cause
I don't know you're gonna find out Isaac
I am glad that Isaac's the same I
thought I was like whoever did the voice
for Isaac I should know that name but it
did a fantastic job
it's weird being back here
it's weird
yeah better keep an eye out there never
know what's in those lockers hey what's
in that Locker
I Don't Mind If I Do Finders Keepers
where's the security detail
where's anybody
I don't know no duty roster no power to
the elevator
for God's sake man it would be terrible
if something jumped out of the ceiling
from us to get us I'm done playing
around
yeah okay you got it boss
it's also very different because Isaac
didn't talk in the first one
oh I didn't notice the blood what do you
need boss
no no I thought that was a glowy
uh damage report yeah okay
ah there's so many details
oh God
what have you got Isaac
uh is bad it's not just comes with the
guidance system half the issamura's in
the red engines Hull the tramps
could do that kind of damage to a planet
correct
power to the elevator should be
the disability detected
quarantine activated another malfunction
no the quarantine systems are all fine
better be careful do you hear that yeah
yeah I hear it
oh you actually got a oh no never mind
oh that's not good
get
out of there
doors
I didn't know someone there
I can't see [__]
I am running what do you think I'm doing
I know how this works oh I can't see how
this works
I'm safe thank goodness
more
like I know it's a remake but I'm so
curious as to how they're gonna kind of
like subvert expectations because I know
this game very well not only did I play
it for a video but I played it again to
beat it on hearted the hardest
difficulty I did the same thing with
dead space too
I don't remember that do I remember that
can I stomp you
oh come on
oh
wow
you'd think that I would have had
something to say about all this but
again it was a silent protagonist in the
past so I didn't say nothing but what
was there in the past that not many
people probably looked into was there
were always logs what the hell were
those things personal Journal you know
I'm writing as I'm scrambling and I'm
running like what the what are those
things they got Chen I'm cut off from
Daniels and Hammond I need to get
somewhere safe yes I do
but no species now I know that cut off
their limbs can I stomp you now
yes I can
I get like progressively angrier you
mean there's a dynamic stomp system oh
man this remake is perfect
foreign
[Applause]
I love it God it's good to be back I
know I didn't get a proper intro on this
but who needs it who needs intros intros
are for Chumps oh my God my flashlight
is only when I have this up which is a
good thing because why would I have it
down
this is the USG shimura
and shit's bad here
[Music]
you sound like Henry when he's walking
like a turkey
I know some people were like oh it's too
right what is this
hello
I didn't die we shot that [__] right
between the eyes and it didn't die Smith
had to shoot his [__] arms and legs
off for God's sakes and help
okay well I'm well versed in this
oh yeah just in case
some keys
just in case hello
now see I'm not gonna remember
everything in specific detail and I'm
willing to bet that they will change
some stuff but I'm I'm kind of glad that
this intro is the same well hey oh my
God Isaac you made it just
they're everywhere Jim is he uh he's
gone nothing I can do
what the [__] are these things the ones
I saw
some of them were wearing a shimmery
uniforms they're the crew how the hell
can they be the crew look at them
we need to get to the bridge there's a
thousand people on board someone will be
there we can't the tram system's wrecked
everything's locked down because of the
quarantine and you're both repair techs
so how do we do this
take it away
there's a broken tram car blocking the
tunnel it's spread off the system and
the data boards burned out I can't lift
the lockdown or call the tram until we
get a spare from the maintenance Bay but
it's all an Isaac side of a quarantine
I'll handle it
just make sure there's power to the
repair systems
and Isaac yeah I'm sure Nicole's okay
she's a doctor right she'll do the smart
thing yeah
yeah she always does
find somewhere safe
that is the last I'm gonna talk about
the comparisons between remaking and
original I don't want to taint this
experience with anything going forward
so I'm going to approach this with brand
new baby eyes lyxian please delete all
of my memories
well it saved
were you
hey cool game
I need a data board for the tram system
oh yeah and I can save God
doing the I'll never I don't remember
anything about anything ever I love
saving savings great
I saved
all right okay
look at this
money I like money I love money what are
you give me you plasma energy yes please
okay which way do I need to go
um
your locator knows the way it does it oh
it does doesn't it or maybe it does I
don't know I'm guessing how
do I
do
interesting
how did I do that wait there ah
ah interesting
a quick little blurp but what's over
here in cargo and baggage
what's in cargo baggage
can I have cargo baggage
should I be in cargo baggage
I don't know if I should I don't know if
I should be in cargo baggage uh
thank you
I know how to
I think
I don't know if I'm supposed to be in
cargo baggage yet
what do you think you're doing
now that's a nice stomp uh
turn on
interesting ah
ah well hang on I want to go to storage
wherever the hell that is
y'all got us what
don't even think about it
did you think about it
don't be thinking about it hey wait a
minute
can't get distracted now
that sounds bad whatever that is sounds
horrifyingly bad
I don't like that
I don't like that none
can I get some cargo
whoa
hey
what are you doing
why are you in the walls ah this looks
important thank you
I don't know that was bizarre
God it's dark
God damn
it's like oppressively dark
all right let me see about I know I'm
probably not supposed to go
the maintenance Bay just yet
see
serious hmm
cargo arrival yeah this definitely ain't
the right way but who knows I think I
need to go get something first and then
come here but my curiosity is just
leading me down paths that I want to go
so I'm going to follow it I'm just
quirky like that
I think don't bother shooting those
[__] in the head it doesn't even slow
them down
the only way is hacking them apart
those arms and their legs does that even
kill them or do they jump that movie
I don't know wait a minute
who's doing that
hey hey
oh don't even think about it oh you
missed it oh
okay okay
foreign
echoing through here I know I'm really
big and strong but
oh this is so gosh dang dark
why is it so gosh dang dark in here
I can't see for crap
oh
they did a damn good job here
it's just like when people saw
the uh Doom early gameplay footage they
were like this looks so slow and boring
and then it turned into the most
intensely frantic game you'd ever play
where where where what you don't even
think about it
hey
hear someone else who where what why how
can I not see any of you
you know I make sure they're dead
by stomping them under itty-bitty gooey
bits
you get blown
come on I should have put less explodies
here
it's a work Hazard oh something in there
is this
ah
power door
what is the boom what is the big boom Oh
that is the big boom
okay so where did that power thing go so
cable running over here
oh thank you oh thank you
uh-huh
[Music]
all right so I just made a full circle
I've yet to find where that power goes
it's got to be some other way either
going up or down I think it was up so it
must be uppies
can I get on uppies
can someone give me uppies
puppies
I don't think I can get up easy
who's gooping
Whoopi gooping
again
you gooping bro why are you gooping stop
pooping
can't see nothing
elevator did this go Opie
let's go office
okay good
good good good
weirdly like on edge
I'm sure nothing's gonna jump out of me
at all ever
why would that be oh God damn you
[Applause]
anybody else
yes anybody else anybody else want a
little
tussle with this muscle
stop being you
all of you everything stop
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I'm weirdly on edge
this is apprehensivating
my knee
well not money ammo hello text log
USC ishimura aerospace engineering
department shuttle repairs invoice
Mission day two fall T4 gyro replaced
faulty 40 scope repairing uh impulsers
complete replacement damage four and
left viewports damage boosters this is
just boring
why do I care about that I don't which I
mean it makes sense that's what I
probably would find anyway
um
are you telling me there's lights on in
here
oh God
oh God no
oh you gotta be kidding me
oh you're joking me
stop
[Applause]
all right
oh
stop wamping into that thing please
oh boy
all right
okay we're in business we're in business
we're in good company and everything is
going swimmingly
I'm not worried why would I be worried
I'm not worried
Mario Warriors right
uh
-huh
yeah peekaboo
peekaboo why are you up there don't do
it don't do it don't come after me don't
do it don't don't come after me no don't
I'm helpless oh I'm just a sweet little
baby
thank you
hey wait don't don't don't come after me
oh you're quick oh my God
don't do it don't come after me don't
I'm helpless I'm helpless thank you
thank you for your patronage
your donation is appreciated the big
preach the priests on the the money Dono
big priest
all right so this is now open great this
was worth it
worth
hugely worth pay a data board
we can't stay here much longer hearing a
lot of movement I'm halfway done found a
data board just gotta move the tram okay
Daniels watch that door
okay
all right M Smith from J Wright poker
night okay keeping this off rig Link in
case Benson's listening poker uh I'm in
but can you not invite Javi this time I
know he's still blaming himself for
Rosie's accident and everything but no
one wants to hear about any of his
[__] nightmares especially that one
where we he saw it's Rosie up and
walking around with half his head
missing don't
we did
and don't give me [__] about it I'm
serious it's messing with me last night
I had one of the dreams where you wake
up you know but my dad was sitting next
to my bed talking to me felt so real I
kept seeing him out of the corner of my
eye trust me that's one son of a [__]
who needs to stay dead
interesting
they are Branch sweet
all right wow
I like that
all right but I don't
think
oh I love the node tree
I love the node tree I don't think I'm
gonna spend any just yet mostly because
I don't know if I'm gonna need these
nodes down the road I don't know I
always like to hold back right I just in
general in games in in general other
games
non-specifically
going home
[Applause]
thanks for the Dono
hey
you little pee pee pants over there
doing a little pee pee pants dance
well come find me
if you brave enough
you're gonna come find me
or am I gonna get out of here oh looks
like I missed it
whoa whoa
hey oh behind me oh
PP man
oh baby bear dance man
huh
little BB dance
what what
are we done
man
you better be done you better be done
you better be done
I love saving
this is a bit of a heart attack and a
half
owl ass
say Lavie let me just turn off the power
to that one because I don't know if I
want to keep that accessible
oh wait a minute you're not supposed to
be there
found the prospector
all right good good good good good
rolling in
hey what is up
you guys still there
uh guys
okay
go go go go go guys
what does a green mean the greens just
mean highlighted or is green mean like
I've gotten all the things
who knows nah it's just highlighted
okie dokie then imma go off it this way
foreign
that's fine right guys that's fine
what happened
I don't know how but they they managed
to recapture the janky and jankiness of
the corpses even though physics
simulations have improved dramatically
what is happening what's happening
what's happening
oh
that's fine
cool I love stasis now I know why the
game wanted me to go this way first
my god I've got a stasis meter
on both of our backs look at this
totally available in cloakbrand.com
you can get it among other really cool
stuff there's various different designs
but show off how stable you are with
your stasis I for what was the tutorial
how to
be uh I didn't catch the button I needed
to press for stasis
yeah I did it I'm good never mind I'm
going for it oh wow how did I almost
mess that up
um
well that's probably not good but glad
things are working at 110 efficiency
that's the best
CD you stay suspect oh it probably just
automatically uses it when I
need
that tickled my brain
okay
well that was cool let's never do it
again
[Music]
I love saving
and yes
all right bathroom oh my God wait error
days
I don't know what that means
uh
I found
a man inside the vents
congratulations
sorry about
I don't trust
what's the heartbeat about
why was there a rapidly increasing
heartbeat
huh
it's gonna be so easy to miss things in
here
I'm never gonna get everything
okay goodbye
well
hey poop dungeons Santa is for error
days great good
great never clean who needs it
I can't get through here
I must be able to go that way then
wait cargo bay I want cargo
hmm
oh
well this looks spicy
claw disengaged great
I love node
I love blasma
I love audio log message
nearing you got
you got damaged tram car on the tracks
and if the whole system is gridlocked
guess who they're calling Temple here
sending a stasis module now
what happened to the other one no idea a
lot of shit's been breaking down and I
keep hearing things
down in the gears where no one could be
you know I know
you know I know you know we know
who doesn't know we know
I know
we all know
ing system re-initialized wow
if only there was something I could do
hold on there before I missed all right
the way hey hey hey hey hey hey what's
behind me there's another one behind me
pop
stay engaged
stay
go
which way we flying but well hello
you dead you gonna be
all right easy all right
[Music]
okay
possibly happen to me
hey
freeze
[Music]
I was making sure there's nothing else
here
oh I knew it
whoa where did you get out of station
you were in timeout
don't do that oh there goes my no hit
run
a good thing I got one please I forgot
what the shortcut is
I think it's cute must be cute nope it's
not cute
I thought it was cute way out one second
f
F
I did it oh whoa whoa where did you go
oh my God you sneaking
I'm heading back to [__] control
should be able to call you a ride on the
bridge good just hurry I keep hearing
noises right under our feet
that's probably fine why is this locked
guys why locked
guys please
oh it keeps seeing
that's just that that's just that okay I
want for good measure all right let's
get you out of here
and never come back again
I love health
no
that's probably fun
I probably don't have anything to worry
about
I'm probably gonna be okay
probably
but how do I get that open
oh well not oh no I'm not good on the
bathroom I'm
oh okay
I thought I heard a musical sting turns
out it's just this door
well I still almost got goosed
how fast is you
that's not thesis
let's not say this is at all
oh
what that's new
that's new
since when could you do that
only a hundred credits
and you're cheap too oh security clear
what do you mean security clearance I'm
an engineer
yeah yeah
all right I gotta get back to my friends
who didn't abandon me my friends who are
definitely there waiting for me and then
we can reunite and together we can beat
back the dark
the darkness
guys guys
good guys
guys
you're there right
oh there you are hey Buddies
you guys gonna we're gonna sync up right
I see you in there
I I see you you talking to me guys
uh guys
we're on board something hit the roof
but it seems operational quarantine
lockdown's lifted so you can get to the
hangar columns are still down so be
ready
when Johnson picks up the Kelly we
report to the bridge standard emergency
protocol what protocol Heaven people are
dying here and I'm not losing anyone
else
you stick to procedure we'll get through
this
we'll see
uh Johnston you mean broken ankle
Johnston is uh are they is they still
there
do you think that they're still there
do you think that is okay is there a
lock on that door
you're a locky door door locky
door locking thing
why the violins now
why would there be violence plucking
happily in the distance
better be dead
again with the plink plonking
can't say it's my favorite thing
hello
oh
foreign
okay
[Applause]
okay okay
everything is a-okay
[Music]
a peekaboo
I see you
anybody oh you don't don't you be oh
whoa
hey cool
I'll be right with you I got some flies
quite the
quite the everything going on
I don't know exactly what to make of
that but uh
probably all fine wow
you serious right now you serious
you serious right now
you serious with this
what no no no
naked ones I I don't need that no one
needs that
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey you naked
I'm not about that
all right things are getting a little
bit too frantic here we need to all calm
down a little bit Johnston how's the
ankle made it to the bridge it's
there's no survivors Daniel's is trying
to get into the command computer
uh-huh
whoa what the heck was that coffee
[Music]
I was just trying to get a snack
hey Johnstone
Johnston
wasn't there a box to stomp in here
thought I remember seeing one before
hey Johnston you still there amazingly
you are
shockingly hey have you been uh in
contact
you uh heard anything
[Music]
I'm coming
don't you worry I'm I'm coming
everything's good don't worry
um yeah you're good
uh
yeah
is that blood Haley I need you to listen
ERS overrun with
[__] monsters you didn't hear
anything what
no the cons are still out Isaac we need
to kill you and fix it now got a damage
report uh yeah it's there
it's kind of incomplete don't you think
um
well you know how it is you probably
would have died in a horrible Lobby
incident
s go
wait but there was a note wasn't there a
note
whoa whoa whoa whoa but there was a note
there
oh my God
but the note
I should that's why I always got to go
for the things beforehand because
otherwise whoa
hey beautiful
don't do that
hello ugly
hey Well audio logs Mario smog that's
what I always say
uh and I could probably get it later
hey whoa wait a minute
how are you still moving
oh hi
what's happening
Kelly until
Singularity core overloaded
no
Killian was our only way home we're
trapped no I'm not losing two good
people for nothing
what about the command computer it's a
the brick all the primary systems are
locked down with the captain's coats so
we find Captain Matthias track his rig
I'm so mad too
oh
okay here did Benjamin Matthias location
Medical
status deceased he was a captain
Isaac
you can double back and cut through
maintenance find the captain's body and
get his rig with his codes we
what was that
chin okay
[Applause]
he's probably fine
what
[Music]
uh-huh
okay
love that movie
that's my favorite one what no nothing
who's my own mind playing tricks on me
is it darker in here than it was
it was that baby always there
a log
I'm not gonna miss it this time
disclaimer this article is sponsored by
cec's Prince publishing division may not
represent the views of the main screen
don't care who cares wham bam bam I bet
that one audio or text log in the issue
Mora or uh the whatever our shuttle name
was the shuttle marmota I bet that was
like the most important piece of lore
that anybody could possibly find in the
game and would unlock all the secrets
all the secrets and all the
understanding of everything in this game
forever and ever and ever and ever
bathroom
Don't Mind If I Do
I love that there are no doors
very
helpful
am I taking this
is this what we're doing
all right I'm doing it but I don't trust
it just like I don't trust anything ever
forever
so
I want that
I don't trust you you you you you
don't trust me you definitely don't
trust you
[__] this ship it's a shitty capitalist
organization
yeah
but maybe I can get a suit upgrade
probably not though
we just shoot upgrade I can afford it
bonus
[Music]
well my suit was kind of bloody already
what is that what is that nonsense what
are these give yourself to the marker be
armored in its word and make the
Brethren whole again I don't know if
that's a good idea have you remembered
whose blood it is yet not really
the colors of the EDF core of and
Virginia is adopted after their Victory
europa's Connemara chaos iceworks during
the resource Wars infested suit Lone
Survivor
classic
I kind of want to see how bad this
infested one looks guys trust me I'm I'm
good I feel good I just feel so good
where's my guts
wait
guys I don't feel so good
guys I don't know uh
I don't know if this is for me oh wait
let me get a good look at this thing
oof I don't know guys
like girl man this is great inspiration
uh for a super cool look love the double
skull bony thing going on there not sure
about this one I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna pass I'll pass I'll pass who what
else could I sell I don't need two men
who needs two med pack I'm never gonna
be in trouble
and there's stasis I barely use it
anyway
I don't need it
buy unlimited oh my God now I want an
upgrade
uh yes please
there we go I can't tell what got added
maybe some bracers things going on here
a little more doodadery in the back
that sounds pretty good
all right cool go go cool
right so my inventory should have
expanded to 18 slots good good great
great
okay two Medical
I thought I took the tram to Medical
ain't I supposed to take the tram to
Medical
bench
Ben
[Music]
oh graph has been extended
oh man I just don't know if I really
size
my suit can do that for me
impressive all right but I don't need it
I'm good yeah I'm gonna hold on until I
um because I don't know if I'm gonna do
just plasma cutter I usually
well I mean I imagine it's such a good
reliable weapon that when it's fully
upgraded you don't really need anything
else I've always found that it's just
like the most suitable weapon for the
job for almost anything but I'm gonna
hold off a little longer before
committing to that because that's kind
of like the habit I I tend to fall on in
games sorry buddy are you sleeping
apologies where'd your head go
I don't know why I'm flabbergasted
because I was the one stomping
but Al ass
quarantined huh I don't have the
security clearance
I don't know what it's all about
medical cargo Depot I don't know what
that means what's hissing me
what is the noises what's with the
noises what is that about
am I gonna get a kinesis
I think I'm gonna get a Kinesis
oh my God
well
fascinating it looks like we've reached
the end of chapter one which means we've
reached the end of this episode thank
you everybody so much for watching and
thank you for joining me on the remake
of dead space this is a very this is a
very cool one for me it's good to see it
and I think
it's going to be a very fun one so get
ready for a lot more very soon
and as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye